find the probability of getting exactly
two heads when flipping three coins so
let's think about the sample space here
let's think about all of the possible
outcomes so I could get all heads so on
flip one I get a head flip two I get a
head flip three I get a head I could get
two heads and then a tail I could get
heads tail heads or I could get heads
tails tails I could get tails heads
heads I could get tail heads tails I
could get tails tails heads or I could
get tails tails and Tails these are all
the different ways that I could flip
three coins and you can maybe say that
this is the first flip the second flip
and the third flip now so this right
over here is the sample space there's
eight possible outcomes let me write
this the probability of exactly two
heads exactly exactly two heads - I'll
say H is therefore short the probability
of exactly two heads well what is the
size of our sample space I have eight
possible outcomes so eight this is
possible outcomes or the size of our
sample space possible outcomes and how
many of those possible outcomes are
associated with this event you could
call this a compound event because
there's more than one outcome that's
associated with this well so let's think
about exactly exactly two eyes this is
three heads so it's not exactly two
heads this is exactly two heads right
over here this is exactly two heads
right over here there's only one head
this is exactly two heads this is only
one head only one head no heads so you
have one to three of the possible
outcomes are associated with this event
so you have three possible outcomes
three outcomes associated with event
three outcomes outcomes satisfy satisfy
this event or associated with this event
so the probability of getting exactly
two heads when flipping three coins is
three outcomes satisfying this event
over eight possible outcomes so it is
3/8